Guten Tag. Ich heiße Dr. Kokmas. Ich bin der Diensthaber der Ars auf dieser Station. Ich würde mit Ihnen Aufnahmegespräch führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden sprechen, möchte ich ganz schön Ihre persönliche Daten aufnehmen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Andrea Krabb.
Krabb mit K, L, A und W.
K, R, A und 2 mal P.
P.
Okay. Frau Krabb, oder?
Ja, Frau Krabb.
Okay. Frau Krabb, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Am 26. März 1966.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
1,70 m.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
70 kg.
Okay, Frau Krabb. Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, ich habe so seit ca. 5-6 Stunden ziemlich starke Schmerzen im Bereich des Brustkorbes auf der linken Seite.
Okay. Wie stark sind diese Schmerzen?
Oder wie beschreiben Sie die Schmerzen?
Die Schmerzen sind manchmal etwas stechend, besonders wenn ich einatme, wenn ich tief Luft hole.
Und auch wenn ich mich drehe oder bewege, dann tut das auch sehr stark weh.
Okay.
Dann sind Sie zu...
Bei bewegen, okay.
Momentan haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Ja.
Okay. Ich werde unsere Sprech unterbrechen und ich schreibe eine EKG.
Und ich nehme Ihre Levenparameter.
Ja.
Was heißt das? Parameter?
Vitalparameter.
Ja.
Und Ihre Brut durch, Ihre Pulse und Zauerstoffstätige.
Also, okay. Ja.
Okay, das ist ein Problem, oder?
Können wir weiterführen?
Ja.
Okay.
Frau Krabb.
Frau Krabb, gibt es eine Auslöser für diese Schmerzen?
Wissen Sie?
Ja, ich habe vor...
Heute, Vormittag habe ich etwas Tennis gespielt.
Und es kann sein, dass es nach dem Tennisspielen auftrat.
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Ich habe solche Schmerzen bisher noch nicht gehabt.
Okay. Vorher haben Sie nichts.
Nein.
Sie haben gesagt, diese Beschwerden treten bei Atmen auf.
Wenn ich so ganz leicht atme, dann nicht so doll.
Aber wenn ich tief einatmen will, oh, das geht gar nicht,
weil das tut dann am Ende so weh.
Haben Sie Atmenprobleme? Atmennot?
Ja, so ein bisschen, weil ich kann immer nur so etwas oberflächlich atmen.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwohin aus?
Ja, ich habe den Eindruck, Sie sind mehr so ein bisschen hinten.
Und die Strahlen dann beim tiefen Atmen so nach vorne aus,
also nach vorne in die Brust ein.
Bei Tiefatmen?
Ja, oder bei Bewegung, beim Drehen.
Aber ich verstärkt den Schmerz.
Ich verstehe nicht. Könnten Sie wiederholen?
Wenn ich mich drehe, wenn ich den Oberkörper drehe,
dann wird der Schmerz stärker.
Haben Sie Herzwesen?
Nein.
Oder Herzklopfen?
Wie würden Sie Ihre Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzskala einordnen?
Null ist keine Schmerz und Stehen sehr stark geschmerzt.
Ja, so zwischen sechs und sieben.
Sechs und sieben.
Entschuldigung, ich habe vergessen zu fragen.
Könnten Sie bis Ende zu Sprechen aushalten
oder soll ich eine Schmerz mitgeben?
Nein, ich kann das im Augenblick aushalten.
Okay.
Ich möchte einfach fragen über Ihre allgemeine Zustandstellen.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Nein, übel ist mir nicht.
Oder ist Ihnen schwendlich?
Nein, ist mir auch nicht schwendlich.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schwellen bei Ihrer Beine?
Schmerzen?
Nein, meine Beine sind immer relativ dünn.
Die habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schweiß aus Brut?
Nein, nein, nicht.
Oder nach Schweiß?
Nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Ich kann das Wasser gut halten.
Und Stuhlgang ist regelmäßig, da habe ich keine Beschwerden.
Könnten Sie ausreichend schlafen?
Ja, mein Schlaf ist, glaube ich, gut.
Ich achte auf einen regelmäßigen Schlaf.
Das ist okay.
Okay.
In letzter Zeit haben Sie eine lange Reise gemacht?
Was verstehen Sie unter einer längeren Reise?
Z.B. vielleicht vier oder mehr Zeit,
nur in einem Auto oder im Flugzeug bleiben?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Frau Kroff, haben Sie irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen?
Z.B. Blutzucker oder irgendwelche?
Ich habe seit ungefähr fünf Jahren einen hohen Blutdruck.
Da nehme ich auch ein Medikament für ein.
Was nehmen Sie ein?
Das Mittel heißt Lisinopridl.
5 Milligramm, da nehme ich eine Tablette am Morgen
und eine Tablette am Abend.
Lisinopridl, ich verstehe gut.
Okay, 5 Milligramm.
Und noch etwas?
Da nehme ich noch ein Medikament für die Schilddröse L-Tyroxin.
50, 1 morgens.
Da bin ich operiert worden.
An einer zu großen Schilddröse, die auch einen Knoten hatten.
Total, ganz eine Schilddröse entfernt wurden?
Nein, man hat gesagt, man hat einen Teil stehen gelassen.
Ein kleiner Teil hat man belassen.
Aber der große Teil der Schilddröse ist wohl entfernt worden.
Okay, wegen einer...
Die Schilddröse war zu groß und sie hatte noch einen Knoten.
Okay, verstehe.
Die L-Tyroxin nehmen.
Und gibt es noch etwas?
Sonst nehme ich keine Medikamente.
Und wann die diese Operation...
Das war vor fünf Jahren.
Okay.
Und in der Kindheit bin ich operiert worden.
Ja.
Neun Jahre alter bin ich an den Mandeln operiert worden.
Und mit elf Jahren am Blinddarm.
Mandel, Operation mit sieben Jahren, oder?
Mit neun Jahren.
Okay, Frau Croft.
Sind die vollständig geimpft gegen auch Corona?
Ja, bin ich.
Ich habe inzwischen vier Impfungen gegen Corona.
Und sonst sagt mein Hausarzt, sind meine Impfungen
für Mitteleuropa, für Deutschland,
alle aktuell auf dem aktuellen Stand.
Okay, sehr gut.
Ist Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien oder Unvertragigkeit bekannt?
Ja, ich vertrage nicht so gut Kiwi.
Ein Ausschlag am Mund, Gläschen.
Und ich vertrage auch nicht so gut Erdbeeren.
Unvertragigkeit, oder?
Ja, ich esse sie auch nicht mehr,
weil danach bekomme ich auch so ein Brennen im Mund.
Und das ist dann nicht gut.
Okay, Frau Croft.
Ihre Regelbelutung ist regelmäßig in der Periode?
In den letzten zwei Jahren nicht mehr regelmäßig.
Besuchen Sie Ihre Frau als regelmäßig?
Ich gehe regelmäßig zur Vorsorge untersuchen.
Sehr gut.
Frau Croft, rauchten Sie?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Sehr gut. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber unregelmäßig.
Vielleicht einmal pro Woche ein Glas Wein.
Aber das ist auch nicht immer.
Oder wenn mal ein Feuer ist, ein Geburtstag ist dann trinke ich
vielleicht auch mal ein Glas Wein, aber nicht mehr als ein Glas Wein.
Okay, sehr gut.
Nächste Frage ist eine Routine Frage.
Haben Sie Erfahrungen mit Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Frau Croft, ich möchte ein paar Fragen über Ihre
Familienstand und Familiengeschichte stellen.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Der Vater war ja 80 Jahre alt,
an einem Schlaganfall verstorben.
Die Mutter ist jetzt 86 Jahre alt,
die hat hohen Blutdruck auch
und schwere Hüftartrose.
Okay.
Sind Sie operiert?
Nein, die Mutter, an der Hüfte, nein.
Sie möchte sich nicht operieren lassen,
aber sie hat schwere Probleme.
Okay.
Wie ist die Familienstadt?
Ich bin verheiratet und habe zwei Kinder.
Die sind 30 und 26 Jahre alt.
Die sind gesund.
Sehr gut.
Sie leben mit ihrer Familie, ihrer Mann.
Sie leben nicht mehr bei uns, die wohnen woanders.
Was machen Sie bei der Frisch?
Ich bin Lehrerin.
Aber sind Sie stressig bei Arbeit?
Ich bin sehr stressig.
Ich mache etwas zum Ausgleich.
Ich mache Spiele, Tennis und Yoga.
Ich mache ein gutes Ausgleich.
Sehr gut.
Frau Krop, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas fragen?
Was kann dieser Schmerz sein?
Ich kann mir keine richtigen Erklärung geben.
Eigentlich kann ich momentan nicht sagen,
was Sie haben.
Ich werde ein paar Blutstests
und Bildverfahren führen.
Ich werde eine kleine Erklärung geben.
Einige Erklärungen werden dann wieder gesprochen.
Das können wir so machen.
Haben die Kollegin andere Fragen?
Ich frage mich,
dass sie in einer anderen Körperregion sind.
Sie fragen mich,
Im Brustkorb und beim tiefen Atmen strahlt sie nach vorne aus, in die Brustreihen Richtung Brustbein.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Entschuldigung?
Nein, ich habe kein Fieber.
Hat sich gewischt in der letzten Zeit ab- oder so genommen?
Verhandelt sich?
Nein, ich habe mein Gewicht in den letzten zehn Jahren immer gehalten.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe eine Schwester, die ist zwei Jahre jünger als ich, die ist gesund und ein Bruder, der ist ein Jahr älter als ich.
Und der hat auch einen blöden Blutdruck.
Aber sonst geht es dem auch ganz gut.
Haben Sie einen Unfall beim Tennisspielen gehabt?
Beim Tennisspielen?
Nein, ich kann mich nicht an einen Unfall erinnern. Ich bin auch in letzter Zeit nicht gestürzt oder so.
Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es durch das Tennisspielen heute kam. Aber so direkt danach fing der Schmerz an.
Haben Sie irgendwo Taubhausgefühl?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Eine Frage.
Haben Sie während dieser Tennisspielen außergewöhnliche Geräusche gehört?
Geräusche? Nein.
Da war ich so konzentriert beim Tennisspielen. Das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Nein, kein Geräusch habe ich so nicht bemerkt.
Okay, danke schön.
Haben Sie Haarthorstwacht bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich bisher nicht bemerkt.
Nein, nichts Auffälliges.
Könnte ich Sie sagen, dass es nicht so ist, dass es nicht so ist.
Nein, das ist nicht so.
Nein, nichts Auffälliges.
Könnten Sie die Arsatzgeschichte anfangen?
Ein paar Minuten möchte ich brauchen.
Die Schmerzen sind mit der Zeit nicht verändert, oder verschlechtert?
Nein, verschlechtert haben Sie sich nicht, aber auch nicht verbessert.
Sie sind plötzlich angefangen, aber relativ plötzlich.
Das war jetzt nicht so wie ein Schlag, aber es baute sich relativ schnell auf innerhalb von einer Viertelstunde.
Eine Viertelstunde? Nein, bis sechs Stunden, Sie haben gesagt.
Seit sechs Stunden habe ich die Schmerzen, Sie fingen an und dann war es eine Viertelstunde, ungefähr da war der Schmerz richtig da.
Richtig, okay.
Sie haben schon diese gleiche Unterricht gemacht.
Unterricht?
Ja.
Diese Fall, vorher haben Sie gemacht.
Sie können sich gut erinnern, aber ein ähnlicher Fall.
Einiger Fall.
Ja.
Dankeschön.
Am Anfang.
Okay.
Guten Tag, mein Oberarzt.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin.
Ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen, aber nicht, dass ich das seitensweise.
Ja, habe ich.
Andre Kropft ist 56 Jahre Patientin.
Sie kann heute seit fünf bis sechs Stunden, bis 10 Uhr, Brutschmerzen zu uns.
Die Schmerzen hat nach dem Sport plötzlich aufgetreten.
Sind nach dem Sport aufgetreten? Was für ein Sport war das?
Den tennis spielen.
Sie wissen, ob die Frau mit welchem Hand die Frau tennis spielt, mit rechts oder mit links?
Links, links Seite.
Die Schmerz.
Ich habe ihn nicht gefragt.
Aber Schmerzen liegt in links Seite.
Die Frau ist links und spielt links-seitig tennis.
Ja.
Und laut der Patientin liegen die Schmerzen bei 6 bis 7 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Aber in Ruhe oder nur bei Belastung oder tiefatmen?
Ich habe mich gefragt.
Sie haben gefragt, was der Schmerz verstärkt.
Der Schmerz verstärkt sich beim tiefen Einatmen?
Ja, bei tiefen Atmen und bei Bewegung.
Ja, aber tiefatmen und bei Bewegung.
Ja, beim Inspiration ist der Schmerz stärkt bei 6 bis 7 oder in Ruhe.
Die Schmerz ist akzentuiert oder verstärkt bei tiefen Inspiration und bei Bewegung.
Ja, und die Schmerz liegt bei 6.
Ja.
Nach Frage.
Herr Rasen, Herr Skloffen,
bei Ödem, nause, vertigo, Fiba, wurde verneint.
Anfallkrankungen leidet sie arteriale Hypertonie seit 5 Jahren.
Und deswegen nimmt sie diesen April 5 Milligramm morgens abends ein.
Die wurde vor 5 Jahren Triadokotomiert.
Und deswegen nimmt sie Elthoxin 50 Milligramm morgens.
Was war die Ursache für die Thüriodektomie?
Die hat wegen Trööts Vergrößerung.
Wegen Stromer?
Stromer, ja, wegen Stromer.
Stromer, nur Dosa.
Sie hatte eine Stromer mit einem Pnoten.
Und sie wurde auch mit 11 Appendermiert und mit 9 Tonselnoktomiert.
Sie ist vollständig geimpft.
Gegen Kiwi und Albert hat sie Unverträglichkeit.
Seit 2 Jahren ist ihre Periode unregelmäßig.
Sie ist gelegentlich ein Glas Wein.
Sie ist verheiratet.
Sie ist ein Kind.
Sie ist ein Lehrer von Begriff.
Als Familie geschickt.
Sie ist in der Apoplexy gestorben.
Sie hat eine Arteriellehypertonie.
Sie hat zwei Geschwister.
Eine Schwester und eine Bruder.
Die Schwester ist gesund.
Und die Bruder hat auch Arteriellehypertonie.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose bei diesen geschilderten Beschwerden?
Aufgrund der anganistischen Angaben,
gehe ich von einem Sportverlustverlust aus.
Es könnte sein eine Präldung oder eine Distortion.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommt auch die KRK.
Der Corona-Zentrum.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose abzuklären,
werde ich erstmal die EKG-Körpereche untersuchen.
Ich werde die EKG-Körpereche untersuchen.
Als Blüte werde ich die EKG-Körpereche untersuchen.
Also ein Notfalllabor auch bezüglich eines kardialen Ereignisses.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass Sie, wenn Sie die Patientin körperlich untersuchen,
die Diagnose zu 90 % stellen können.
Nur aufgrund der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Eine Druckschmerzung vielleicht?
Die Patientin gibt an, heute Tennisgespiel zu haben.
Sieht einen gewissen Zusammenhang vielleicht mit dem Tennisspiel.
Nach dem Tennisspiel hat sie diese Schmerzen verstärkt gespürt.
Und der Schmerz ist verstärkt bei Inspiration und bei Bewegung.
Kostet er sich mit dem Brot?
Wenn Sie dann die körperliche Untersuchung machen,
ein Kollege hat gefragt, gibt es Hauteffluoreszenzen,
vielleicht im Sinne eines Herbst-Zoster?
Nein, hat sie nicht.
Und dieser Schmerz, glaube ich, bei Herbst-Zoster,
ob er so schnell auftritt, der baut sich, glaube ich, länger auf.
Über mehrere Tage oft, dass die Patienten beschwerden haben,
bevor überhaupt eine Hauteffluoreszenz kommt.
Das kann schon sein.
Aber diese Patientin hat an TH6, links, linksparaverteberal
einen umschriebenen Druckschmerz, eine Myogelose.
Man geht davon aus.
Ich würde jetzt erst mal sagen, die Patientin hat,
und das ist sehr oft in der Praxis,
ein akutes BWS-Syndrom mit vielleicht einer Rippenblockierung.
Und dies strahltypischerweise bei der Inspiration auch an der Rippe entlang,
sozusagen im Nervenverlauf nach vorne aus, zum Sternum.
Sie müssen auf alle Fälle natürlich die kardiale Seite beachten.
Das haben Sie am Anfang schon gemacht.
Da haben Sie gesagt, ich mache ein EKG, ich untersuche die Vitalparameter.
Das war sehr gut.
Und differenzial diagnostisch muss man natürlich das Kardiale
ganz in den Vordergrund stellen,
weil das könnte einen eventuell ungünstigen Verlauf nehmen.
Ein akutes BWS-Syndrom macht erst mal nur Schmerzen,
aber ist nicht vital bedrohlich.
Zu Ihrer Schilderung oder zu Ihrer Schilderung vor dem Oberarzt
sollten Sie darauf achten, dass Sie gleich zu Anfang eben sagen,
die Patientin klagt über seit circa 6 Stunden bestehender Toraxschmerzen
oder Torakala-Beschwerden und nicht Brustschmerzen.
Das sollten Sie versuchen, möglichst gleich in den Fachbegriff überzuführen.
Nachher haben Sie viele Fachbegriffe gebraucht.
Das war gut.
Aber im Anfang denken Sie daran, Brustschmerz möglichst gleich übersetzen
in Torakala-Beschwerden oder linkseitige Torakala-Beschwerden,
die eher vom Dorsal nach ventral einstrahlen.
Das könnte man so ganz kompliziert nennen.
Ich gehe davon aus, wie gesagt, dass es sich eher um ein akutes BWS-Syndrom
handelt und nicht um ein kardiales Syndrom.
Sie haben abgefragt mit der Beinstellung.
Ich hätte vielleicht vorher noch gefragt, ob sie in der letzten Zeit
operiert worden ist oder ob sie ein Sturzereignis hatte.
Das haben Sie, glaube ich, nicht gefragt.
Es gehört vielleicht noch dazu, ob irgendwo eine Trauma an am Nese war.
Aber sonst finde ich, haben Sie das systematisch gemacht
und sich gekümmert um die Patientin.
Sie haben in Partie gezeigt durch EKG und gefragt,
ob sie ein Schmerzmittel braucht.
Alles sehr gut.
Danke.
Ja.